the concept of the Superman is one of
the strangest most fascinating ideas in
philosophy we find it coined by
Friedrich Nietzsche in his book of 1883
thus Spoke Zarathustra on first hearing
it we can't help but think of the action
hero Superman described by his creators
as faster than a speeding bullet more
powerful than a locomotive and able to
leap tall buildings in a single bound
these are actually very good starting
points
DC Comics were asking themselves what
someone would be like who was physically
far superior to all current human beings
Nietzsche is asking himself a very
similar question only he's interested in
psychological qualities in thus spake
Zarathustra Nietzsche points out that
evolution cannot be assumed to have
finished human beings have evolved from
apes but what is ape to man he asks in
some respects like imagination and
science were obviously far superior to
our ancestors so how my people of the
future be superior to who we are today
Nietzsche's characters Arethusa rest'
asked is to speculate about what the
Superman the more advanced person of
tomorrow will be like Nietzsche wasn't
interested in massively enhanced brain
power and ability to do hugely complex
sums in one's head or to learn a
language in three days rather he was
developing a crucial thought experiment
suppose we were psychologically superior
to people today what would we be
actually like what is the ideal kind of
human being and he came up with a very
surprising and challenging answer
Nietzsche's strategy for answering his
own question was to identify the person
he most admired the person he thought
had the best approach to life and then
homed in on the qualities that made this
person the way they were
he was particularly impressed by Johann
Wolfgang von Goethe whom he regarded as
the nearest anyone had yet come to being
a Superman he also took some hints from
Napoleon Mort Ain Voltaire and Julius
Caesar
he concluded that supermen are going to
have some wonderful and sometimes
unexpected characteristics they will
make their own values they'll be very
independently minded they
won't ask what do other people admire
and follow along they'll carve their own
path supermen accept that they might
need to hurt people in the name of great
things they can be selfish in strategic
ways greatness for them will be about
the reform of humanity towards pagan
values the values of Goethe supermen
will never be resentful of the success
of others they'll accept suffering as a
necessary component of good things
they'll understand that they're hard to
understand and that therefore they may
often be lonely they'll be gentle
towards the weak out of consciousness of
their own great strengths there'll be a
little bit wicked around sex by
conventional standards they'll not be
humble but rather delight in their own
abilities they'll be interested in the
practical application of culture to
raise the mentality of society Nietzsche
thought we would be surprised and
sometimes a bit shocked by his list he
thought would be expecting that the
superhumans of tomorrow would be deeply
compassionate very Galit Aryan
uninterested in rivalry and perhaps have
ambitions to make breakthroughs in
science but Nietzsche was arguing
something else that maybe being great
involve some qualities that are a bit
disturbing and also the greatness beans
being interested in the salvation of
mankind through culture the word
Superman is useful for getting us to
think about who we would like to evolve
into each of us should under Nietzsche's
guidance have a sense of what we would
like to be if we could be the super
version of ourselves the idea of the
Superman helps us to refine our own
ambitions
you